show you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney best-selling author and
ramsey personality
host of the dr john dolone podcast which
is exploding
across america in a good way is my
co-host today
so you can talk to him here on the air
as a part of the show the phone number
is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
talk about your life your money and your
life
dr john is known for helping people with
any kind
of mental health type things relational
type things and so
uh answering questions about boundaries
and in-laws
and um you know life when it happens and
it does happen to
all of us so if you want to call in on
his show you can always do so at
844-693-3291 or email ask
john ramseysolutions.com the phone
number here for today
and there are a couple of lines
available triple eight eight two five
five two two five greg is in tulsa
oklahoma
hi greg welcome to the ramsay show hi
how you doing good to talk to you you
too sir what's up
got a question i'm i'm 47 my wife is 56
and we started very late in life and
trying to save
we just paid off all of our debt except
for our house good
so my question is we combined we bring
home about 130 000 a year
phenomenal should i take every should i
take everything and
slam our mortgage or because of our age
and we're starting late
should i put more of that into like etfs
or mutual funds
well i would load up your retirement
accounts 401ks
roth iras and anything where there's a
match or anything where you can get a
roth
first i've got a rough 401k at work
they match three percent up to six so
i've got i'm maxing that out
good and then this year we just started
a roth ira for me in a row for earth
good yeah we're matching that as well
what i want you to do is to
stop that when it gets to 15
of your household income okay
okay and everything above that then goes
to what we call baby step
five kids college if that applies if it
doesn't
buy them out of the house then we move
right on to baby step six and dump
anything above 15 going into retirement
that we can scrape out of the budget on
as extra payments on the house
what typically happens in these
situations and we you can run the math
out on your situation if you want but
what normally happens is the homes paid
for in about seven years
that's where i had figured six and a
half okay and that's what putting 15
of your income into retirement yes see
there we go
okay and that's why because here's the
thing we we want to get to retirement
age
with both of these things done the house
paid for
and a pile of money in the in the 401ks
and the iras
one or the other is okay
neither one done becomes a retirement
crisis right
no money saved in big debt on the house
and you hit 65 or 69 or whatever then
you're screwed
you're really in a mess but uh but
you've got
10 years for your wife 20 years for you
uh
to build wealth and to clear this debt
and so you should be in
very very good shape when you get to
retirement just by following
the baby steps so dave i help me with
this because
this i feel burdened by a mortgage
it kills me to the point that it is hard
for me
at my age to put money in retirement
while this thing's hanging out there
and that's is that a point when the the
psychology
needs to i need to dial that back and it
becomes a math problem
it just kills me man well i would just
take you know a percentage of that kills
me and just put it into
i'm going to be very intentional with
these dollars yeah every dollar that
comes into the house and so everything
about 15
goes on the house and the kills you
keeps you from you know
buying a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar car or a hundred thousand you
know a fifty thousand dollar car or
something
instead of putting it on the house i
don't mean you have to drive a two
thousand dollar car
on the other hand but i'm saying what
that does is that that that
sense of weight or that sense of fear of
not having enough
there's a healthy result in that if you
don't let it build up and it just
becomes toxic
in other words it's a motivator it
pushes you to do the right things
because the weight is real i says am i
crazy no you're not crazy the weight is
real
i mean it's real but don't let it make
you crazy i've never been able to
to demonize
like if i owe somebody something i've i
really feel like i owe them something
right and i i know credit card's
different than
student loans different than house but
for me it's all the same
yeah i mean it's all it's all a debt
that's right and the borrower's still
slaving to the lender and what you're
experiencing is the emotional
relational spiritual part of slavery
right then you feel it
and so um somebody else is going to
participate in me deciding what i'm
going to do with my life
yeah yeah i don't want any bankers
bellying up to my kitchen table that's
it you know that's what it comes down to
but i invited them too right yeah
john is in indianapolis hey john how are
you i'm doing fine dave how are you
today
better than i deserve what's up good i
just had one question
um in 2007 my wife and i
took one of your uh your financial peace
university class through our library
and it served us very well down through
the years and
i'm about two years away from retirement
and i've been investing in the
40 c 40 percent s and 20 percent i like
you recommended um
and it's done very well and my question
is i'm about two years out in retirement
at what point
do i possibly slide that over into a
more safe
less risky friend or do i keep my foot
on the gas pedal until i walk out the
door
how old are you i'm 58
5 8 yes okay well i'm 60 and i have not
moved anything to conservative investing
now what you may do when you do retire i
probably would come out of the thrift
savings plan and do a rollover into an
ira
and sit down with smartvestor pro and
develop a portfolio for your retirement
of mutual funds
okay but i'll tell you what my portfolio
looks like it's growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international what
we've taught for
30 years now here's the thing the the
idea that as you hit 60 or hit
retirement that you're supposed to move
money into conservative things is called
asset allocation
and it is a widely believed theory of
investing
among the financial planning community i
personally think it's wrong
i think it's a theory and i think the
theory breaks down here's why
at 60 years old if you move stuff into
bonds and money markets and you start
producing about half the rate of return
that you're producing now
in other words you start making four or
five or six instead of uh 10 or 12
on your money all in the idea that now
we're coasting
into the harbor of retirement and we
need to be super conservative
and we don't want to put anything at
risk the problem with that theory is is
that if you're 60 years old and you're
healthy
statistically you're going to live into
your 90s
the average death age of a male in
america is 76
a female 76 a male is 74 but that
includes infant mortality teenage death
and so on
when you hit 60 years old healthy you
have a very high
probability of living 30 more years so
this is like talking to a 30 year old
and saying you need to invest
conservatively because you're going to
be
60 something yeah you've got 30 years
you've still got to outpace inflation
and so i think this theory is asinine uh
and so
especially if you've got a lump of money
if you're sitting there the half million
a million dollars in these investments
and it sounds like you probably are then
uh
you're not gonna be using the money
anyway you're just gonna be living off
the income it creates the money's gonna
be invested for your kids
you're just gonna live off the income
you're not gonna touch the goose you're
only living off the golden eggs
and so that's my theory i don't think
i'll ever
move mine to conservative investments
because i've got millions of dollars in
it
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
org chministries.org budget
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
his best-selling quick read our first
publishing
effort of his it's called redefining
anxiety
80 page quick read is now available it's
all ten
dollars and um and it's an amazing
amazing quick read so if you have
trouble with anxiety or you know anyone
that does
welcome to planet earth and uh dr john
can walk you through
some issues on that redefining anxiety
be sure you pick up a copy
samantha's with us in dallas texas hi
samantha welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for having me today
sure
how can we help um i was calling because
um i started your program this past
october and
i'm on baby step two and i'm currently
reading the total
money makeover and my question is
something that you talk about
is not giving the government a
interest-free loan for your taxes
and um i get back a pretty hefty
tax return every year and i was just
wondering how i can
set up my taxes so i get more now
to put towards my debt without going
um when i file my taxes next year okay
what was your refund the last two years
um 201 2200. okay
has anything changed substantially in
your life
this year like did you buy a house have
a baby get married
none of this thing okay so nothing
that's going to affect your taxes so
you're likely going to get a
2000 to 2200 refund again
right is that right i can really change
in my deduction correct
okay so uh i would sit down with
uh just go to your payroll department at
your company and say i need to fill out
a form to change my deductions and i
need to help you
you can help me calculate it i need to
change my deductions
by 200 a month
okay i need to bring home 200 more than
i'm bringing home now
that's 2 400 a year so you'll be under
withholding a little bit
so you'll owe a couple of hundred when
you do your taxes next year
if you want to do 150 then you would get
a small refund
that'd be 1800 but uh and and you know
you get a couple hundred dollar refund
that'd be okay too if you want to just
be safe go ahead and just do 150.
let's let's increase your take-home pay
i want to claim enough deductions or
fill out a form
to increase my take-home pay by 150
a month that's 1800 a year and if you
have a 2 000
tax bill that means you i mean if you
have a 2000 refund
that means you wouldn't be getting that
you would have gotten it early except
for
uh 200 of it so you get a 200 refund
instead of a 2 000
tax refund and that would be a very
smart thing to do
so yeah i'll just reduce your three and
let me tell you the the
irs tables don't work so they like
well i'm a single young woman and i
don't have any deduction deductible or i
don't have any
um dependents and so i claim zero
dependence
and then it creates this huge refund so
that
it obviously the calculations on it
don't work so you can't use
what your you know your real number of
dependents are
to set the thing up so you have to
actually just do the math
the other thing if you want to get more
sophisticated on this folks go ahead and
just do your tax return
for this year in advance
and then you'll know exactly what your
tax bill is
and have that amount taken out of your
check
and no more and no less because that's
what you're withholding is not supposed
to be
over withholding and a refund comes from
over withholding now you know while
we're talking about these 2020 taxes
there are some changes you guys need to
know the deadline for federal taxes has
changed
from april 15th to may 17th a handful of
states whose deadlines got pushed to
june 15th because of natural disasters
over the winter
quarterly taxes and state income taxes
are still due
april 15th in a week from now
and the unemployment tax law changed if
you got unemployment benefits in 2020
you do not pay federal income taxes on
the first
ten thousand two hundred dollars unless
your household unless your income was
more than 150
000 in which case your unemployment
benefits are fully taxable
so these are interesting things about
taxes as if there's anything interesting
about taxes but
uh if you're feeling like you can do
your taxes on your own like her
situation where she's got a very simple
return
there's not much to it try filing online
with ramsey
smart tax about 60 000 people have done
it so far this year
it's got all the bells and whistles you
need it's very easy to use it's top
quality no jacked up prices no
bait and switch you can file your
federal taxes with randy smartex for
either
17 or 37 depending on the support you
want
and you're not going to get a deal like
this from turbo tax
so get tax help you can count on and if
you have a complicated return we can put
one of our trusted pros from the elp
program in your corner to help you
so if you want some help with all this
text tax
to 33 789
tax to 33 7
8 9. hey this may be an ignorant
question
why do people wait until
again go back to what a question i asked
earlier just because i get something in
my head and i got to get it done
why do people wait till april 15th is
there a benefit to holding off paying
your taxes
mine are pretty uncomplicated so if you
have to pay
then you would wait until the last
possible minute to give them your money
okay if you're getting a ref a refund
you would file
immediately okay in january and get your
refund as soon as possible
because you want your money back in your
hand and you want to change it but
so going to april allows people to
either earn that money gather that money
get that money yeah that you're gonna
have to pay the government
yeah okay and you have to pay the taxes
whether you file or not
uh and so like in my case we calculate
mine it's
you know more sophisticated formula
around here because i own the company
and all this other crap
and so we calculate mine to where i have
to pay every year
uh and we wait until the last possible
moment to send them that huge
check uh you know we have to pay
quarterly so we have to do some other
stuff there's all kinds of things so
we've already sent in a bunch
but that last big chunk that we are
allowed to wait until the last minute
without penalty we wait on and do it at
the last minute
and it's not because we're
procrastinating it's because i just
don't want to give the government the
money until i have to
let it work for me until it works you
can say yeah at some point it's my
savings account until then
i want to keep earning interest on until
yeah there's no reason to send it to
them early
okay so again if you've got a simple
return let's use this ramsey smart tax
online filing it's very easy
like i said 50 60 000 people have
already done it i did it it was awesome
you used the ram sheets
what i used i did at my kitchen table
knocked my taxes out by myself one
saturday morning called it good
pretty cool it was fantastic well look
at that that's good probably the last
year you'll be able to do that
i hope your life's getting really
getting complicated brother so um
if you need a pro in your corner because
you've got a complicated thing either
one we can help you with that with the
elps or the ramsey smart tech software
whichever one you want to use
and they're both very straightforward
and we're not going to try to sell you a
mortgage loan
while you're doing it or get you a
credit card while you're doing it which
i don't
you know some of these tax filing things
are merely bait and switch
they're just trying to get you in their
database so they can uh sell you
something
so anyway not us that's not what we're
doing
text tax to 33 789
taxed to three three seven eight
nine hey oh good go ahead you're fine i
was gonna tell you i had a um
insurance question for you real quick i
was calling to up some life insurance
the other day and
i called xander and they started telling
me well you know dave recommends and
dave says this and
i asked a question should i do this or
this and they said well dave i said well
hold on
i'll just ask him right because i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna be sitting by him on the
show in a couple days
and so um the difference between buying
i'm upping a policy that i already have
um and
the difference between stopping when i'm
60 versus
stopping when i'm 75 is is significant
and so what do you recommend
for people to when how long should you
buy a policy for it how old
right 15 years max 15-year policy
15 to 20. if you if you're 30 years old
and you want to buy a 20
or you're 25 years old you won't buy 20
that's fine uh
for two reasons one is at the end of 20
years you should be debt-free house and
everything because you took out a
15-year mortgage or less
you paid off all the other debt and at
the end of 15 years you would have been
investing and so you'd have substantial
money and investments
and so um i mean uh
15 years from now your kids will be out
of college
so the life insurance is really gap
insurance
until i can self-insure myself exactly
exactly and if things change in your
life and you need some more as long as
you've not lost your health
it has gotten cheaper almost every year
and so like i bought a policy of 35 and
i bought another one at 40 that was
cheaper at 40
even though i was older the other one i
just upping it was cheaper than the one
because the prices are going down
continually because they continue to
update the
statistical evidence and people are
living longer and that it affects the
prices so 15 to 20-year level term
that's what we recommend
all right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
benji and nicki are with us hey guys how
are you pretty good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
ashland city okay just up the road not
bad
fun and all the way down here to do a
debt-free screen yes
wonderful how much have you paid off 38
452 two dollars and eleven cents
how long did this take ten months good
for you well done
and your range of income during that
time from 82 to 102.
excellent what you guys do for a living
i work i'm a team lead
in accounting department and i work for
the cheatham county highway department
awesome very cool what kind of debt was
your 38 thousand
loans you for those of you listening the
way she just turned and looked at him
was so great go ahead and tell us man
what'd you do
[Laughter]
okay loans credit card you know the
usual yeah
loans and credit cards car debt no
student loan debt no
no no no just buying stuff yes okay
all right how long you all been married
it'll be 20 19 years
in august all right and uh
10 months ago what changed
what happened we had to file bankruptcy
oh
oh then that changed it yeah that'll
change it
a little wake-up call yes and this was
left over from the bankruptcy stuff
it was actually due to be paid off in
2024. oh okay so this was a chapter 13
you cleared
okay filed it in may of 19 and paid it
off in october of
2020. okay
all right and so you got you
tell me the story what happened from may
of 19
december 19 we just paid you know
minimum payment right your normal 13
chapter 13 payments yeah
january 2020 is when we that's when
that i've had a moment come up okay and
then we just started hammering away
okay so uh how did that conversation
happen tell me
unpack the story for us a little bit it
wasn't hard
actually i was in the woods hunting and
just you know a lot of time to think and
i was just thinking i was like you know
i'm
i don't want to live like this i don't
want to keep paying and you know for
that many years
i'll come home and just talk to her and
she's like well let's do it so it was
that easy okay all right and how did you
connect to us
we have a friend that's been you since
he was 16.
okay and he tried to get me on board
years ago and i you know
young didn't have nothing to do with it
and then i was like man i should have
done what he did yet
so nikki you're just look like you were
biting your tongue and you were gripping
your knuckles
what's what's your part the side of the
story it's the thing
the same thing yeah what happened before
the bankruptcy
no just kept piling up and piling up yes
thought we could do it and then it was
like we can't do this anymore we were
living the life
so we thought yeah and then it caught up
with you hit you in the back of the head
yeah
but i believe if i know then what i know
now
we could avoid it bankruptcy but what do
scared people do
yeah you get cornered and yeah i know
i know the feeling brother another
feeling wow i'm proud of you guys yeah
so it sounds like a lot more has
happened than just cleaning up the debt
we come closer we work together as a
team i bet
i bet we might argue a little bit over
the budget sometimes but
it's not easy it was not easy but it but
it's at least
at least it's an argument instead of a
just a blind running crazy
exactly yeah that's good it's good
healthy now keep in mind
she done most of the work she was able
to work from home
you know during the whole pandemic and
all that
so most of this was her okay
so uh now that you're finally clear
after 20 years
of marriage and you got a whole new map
on how to handle money and how to talk
to each other about it
you ever go back in debt no
no you didn't even get to finish that
sentence
yeah well i mean when somebody's sick
and tired of being sick and tired you
can tell right
you're right and that's uh that changes
everything that's that's the
that's the home run because you probably
have been in debt your entire marriage
right most people have
yeah yeah and and now you're clear yes
you thought those stresses were just a
part of being married right
yep just a part of being alive and part
of being alive because
my whole family's been that way you know
we've struggled
make ends meet how does it feel now that
you're clear oh it's great
really good who were your biggest
cheerleaders anybody on the sidelines
telling you
your buddy's got to be one of them he's
a he's about the only one everybody else
if we were crazy or
dumb and now look at me now
how you like me now that's right toby
keith right yeah
good for you guys i'm so proud of you
guys well done
very well done i can just see a
lightness on them they look they
look like they lost it they're nodding
like that guy
that you you look across you know the
old playground
you're like you want some of this and
the guy smiles and goes
they know something the rest of the
world don't know because they do
right that's it that's the look man
exactly the look
so what do you tell that couple that
thinks is like man you just got to be
married 20 years it's going to be a
grind and she's going to be annoying and
he's going to be an idiot he's going to
buy stupid stuff
what do you tell that couple
do it on a budget i mean
that's the key to to getting out of debt
is that budget
and having a plan that you're both
having a plan that you both agree on
you're on a game plan and you said
something i think is important i don't
want to blow by
it's hard and it's still worth it yeah
and he or she is still
worth it yes even though it's hard yes
there's no magic
fairy dust you sprinkle over it and
suddenly making a budget it's fun and
joyful and
no thing you want to do on saturday
mornings right it is very hard
last april if you ask me
i would have never imagined that i'd
have went this far
i mean we actually stuck with it you
know started seeing light at the end of
the tunnel when stuff was getting
smaller and smaller that's what keeps
you going yeah
it is congratulations man well done you
two
you rock stars man i'm proud of you very
very cool
we've got a copy of rachel cruz's latest
new york times bestseller know yourself
know your money for you guys
as a gift and uh we're so proud of you
thank you for coming down here to do
your welcome free screen
all right it's benji and nicki from
ashland city 38 000
paid off in 10 months making 82-102
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two
[Music]
this is how it's done i
love it very very cool andy
is in providence and rhode island hey
andy welcome to the ramsey show what's
up
we're good to have i already talked to
you i uh a little bit about me
i'm late forties i'm single and staying
that way no kid
no hangers on i'm uh everyday
millionaire
as by the end of last year
um congratulations how did you say you
were thank you
great for you late 40s okay cool um
i got about 380 in cash that includes
emergency fund
but my situation is i've never owned a
house
and i've i've been working for quite a
while
you know more serious at times than
others but i feel like it's getting
farther away
yeah with everything that's going on
where i'm looking to move
it's a real tight market and you know
before colgate now it's just crazy
because he spread into the outlying
areas where i was looking
um i'm kind of tired of sitting on this
cash and not see it do anything
good i can certainly get approved for
you know a ridiculous amount of a house
mortgage
but i was really wanting to pay either
cash or
you know cash and maybe a hundred
thousand i think i think cash is a great
question what
what do i do when there's just nothing
in that
range i don't want to wait
that i well i don't know that you ha how
long you have to wait
uh but you can wait a little while i
mean i don't want to wait six years but
i might play with this for six months
take your time keep poking around make
this make this uh
search and adventure i'm looking for the
right deal
for me at this time and i'll know it
when i find it
and until i find it just have a lot of
peace and waiting don't get all caught
up in the heat of the market
and that gives you urgency your only
urgency is you want to own a house
sometime in the next three years
my wife and i went nine months till we
found the gym that nobody else had seen
and just kept blown over
and it worked out and you keep looking
until the real estate agents pissed
yep yep this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five angela is
with us in idaho falls idaho hi angela
how can we help
directly into your phone it was cutting
out on you
i have a financial and relationship uh
problem i'm hoping you guys can help me
solve it we'll try okay
so here's a bit of a back story um i was
all
married for almost 20 years uh we've
been divorced about two years
um i moved out about eight months ago
during the time when we were divorced
but living together
we were trying to work things out but it
didn't work out
we have financial issues with infidelity
that way and relationship infidelity
we have decided we want to try to work
it out
where i'm currently seeing them my lease
is up and i can't afford
rents around here on my own and so my ex
has offered to let me move back in for
half of whether it be paying at rent
anywhere else
and is that okay to do while we're
trying to work things out or should we
stay
separated while we're still trying to
work things out
what what are you still trying to figure
out after 20 years of divorce living
together after divorce and then an eight
month
breakup what is there left to discuss
well
we have trust issues in each other yeah
clearly
so what do you what is gonna
what's gonna be what's gonna come to the
surface here
when you move back into his house and he
uh
he is able to lord over you the fact
that you're paying less
less rent and you can't leave how is
that going to solve a trust issue
well see me moving on it was kind of
proven to him that you can't close that
boundary there's no consequences
yeah see you're so that you're playing
russian roulette
um yeah i know this is hard i it sounds
like your relationship's over
and either he likes having you around
when it's convenient and
you are still hanging on to this myth
this fantasy that
is one day gonna he's gonna bloom and
blossom and grow and he's gonna be the
guy you've always wanted to be
and after 20 years and a divorce
and eight months of giving it another go
it sounds like it's over
yeah well part of it for the future is
how to deal with the drug we left and so
i i know listen listen you're just
accountable for that
it's just it's gonna be one thing after
another after another
and it's so hard i know i don't want to
minimize it
it has been one thing after another
after another after another
and um i'm hearing somebody that doesn't
understand their innate value and worth
maybe i get told that by a few people
you are you are worth not being lied to
and cheated on
again and again you're worth not moving
into a house where someone's going to
say hey by the way i
i got you because i'm charging you a
half rent
you're worth more than someone else's
table scraps
and you've locked yourself into if i
don't do this i can't live here and then
i can't
man there is a big wide open country
lots of places you can go where people
are going to treat you with the value
that you're worth
and i know that's so hard to hear
yeah i guess it's more like maybe me
just
afraid of the change i guess because in
this eight months where
we have been apart i do come almost
over almost every day um it's a bit
complicated
my brother lives with him yeah so i come
and i
see my brother and everything but so
you're not really divorced
no well yeah you've never really ended
the relationship your relationship is
continued yeah
and it's strung on dot dot dot and it
went from the main road to the gravel
road back to the main road
yeah it's just a mess yeah and if you
have a scab and you keep picking it and
you keep
bumping it angela um how old are you
39 okay you having children
um i have one adult child
and how old is your adult child 22
boy or girl boy okay
if he called you up and told you this
story
about him and his girlfriend
what would you tell him
i would tell him to break it off but
it's easier
yeah i said than done
why do you value him more than yourself
not your son your ex yeah
um i kind of feel responsible
i guess for him
and his relapsing because
that's so much issues we were having
before i just saw that
before i know i brought on issues i
no i mean that's just that's just bull
crap there's no possible there's no how
in the
crud can you come up with the idea that
this guy cheating on you you're
responsible for it or him
drugs is your fault that's not whacked
it's not
if your son told you that about his
girlfriend after she's cheating and
sleeping all over town
and he still wants to hang on and he
said but it's my fault she sleeps around
you would smack him
wake up boy that's what you'd tell him
wouldn't you
yeah because he you because you know
your son has value
well we know you have value and this is
just cray-cray girl you need to get away
that's uncle dave talking i have no
psychological degrees dr john's got two
of them but
i'm telling you this i've got a problem
with your brother
yeah your brother doesn't need to be
buddying up with a guy who's
disrespected his sisters
over and over and over again for two
decades the way he has
if your brother had some courage he
would step out and y'all could get an
apartment together and figure this out
while you got your feet underneath you
but
he's not that guy yeah and he does help
me he actually my brother does give me
uh your brother stands there while you
walk back into this toxic relationship
i'm not talking about money look you
called and asked us what to do here's
what we're telling you to do get out
yeah
get away don't have any more contact
with this guy
at all he's your ex treat him like it
move on kiddo and am i missing something
no
yes the the other piece is treat
yourself
like somebody that treats yourself like
you
like you treat the people in your life
that you care about treat yourself at
least as good as your ex how about that
at least show yourself and and do the
work you've got to do
when someone gets that kind of when
someone's mistreating you and you
continually go back to them back to them
back to them back to them
over and over and over again and they
continue a pattern of misbehavior
it is because you don't care enough you
don't have enough self-respect to walk
away
from crap and we're trying to say you
are worth it
you need to walk away and you need to
have zero contact with this guy
if your brother wants to talk to you
it's gonna have to be somewhere else
where this guy's not around and not on
this property
you don't need to be on that property
ever again and you don't need to talk to
this guy
ever again ever period
you owe him nothing this is
over this is so toxic girl
go you need to get plugged into a good
church you probably need to move to a
different city
yeah and start fresh make no mistake
you've been married to somebody for two
you
20 years at that point they're they're a
leg and an arm
it's a part of you this is gonna hurt
once you finally acknowledge this
thing's over
and you start the grieving process two
decades this is over over
it will hurt and hurt and hurt and that
doesn't mean it's wrong
that actually means you're doing the
hard work of cutting that infection out
and now you're going to be on the road
to healing
but you're done with you've got to be
done with it you got to be done like
dave said don't go back
it's over you're worth more than this dr
john deloney just called your ex an
infection
yep yeah and
your brother's not helping he's
certainly not helping
it's time to go get surgery connect
yourself with somebody who will see your
value
and i know it's hard that mirror gets
dusty and dirty sometimes it's hard to
see it
but man i i just hate hearing that in my
heart man yeah you need to get plugged
into a great church
i really think uncle dave's thinking you
need to move to a different city
and get a start because i think you're
going to have to have the physical
distance
to have the courage to stay away yeah
and have that have the discipline to
stay away because your healing's only
going to begin to the extent you stay
awake
you're carrying in your heart his
infidelity his drug
use his fill in the blank his money
issues
man it's a mess you're worth more than
that baby it's a mess it's a massive
smash you don't be mean to him
no you just don't have to be to him
you're already divorced it's over
yeah just you don't have to be it's not
you're not required anymore
your services are no longer needed
wow that puts us hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five as we talk about your
relationships your life
your money anything in your life we're
here to walk
with you through the whole puppy the
whole burrito
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five melissa is with us to kick
off this hour in san francisco
hi melissa how are you hi
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i was wondering how you
recommend um budgeting for people whose
salary or
take-home pay is pre-dependent on
bonuses
okay how long you been doing that
um i'm in my third year right now okay
you're single yeah and uh what do you
make
total so my base right now is
95 000 and my bonus just really
depends on performance what'd you make
last year
i thought that was your base yeah that's
my base and then my bonus was 60
000. okay so you made 150 000 last year
yeah what'd you make the year before
total
um 130. okay good so it's heading up
then
that's good yeah i mean that means
you're performing well on this bonus
program good for you
okay well here here's what um what i
i've lived on
straight commission or an irregular
income being self-employed my entire
life
so i've never been able to do a budget
with a fixed
salaried income i've never been i mean i
teach people how to do it but i've never
done one
so what we have learned to do is a
prioritized
spending plan above what the known
money is now how often do you get these
bonuses
they're yearly once a year yeah
okay and so you're pretty much living on
90 and then this money comes in and you
hit the lottery
basically yeah so they just cut you a
sixty thousand dollar check one week
yeah yeah and that's a heck of a week
it's a whoo-hoo week yeah i like it
my favorite week of the year yeah okay
so uh but so can and you can run your
household on 90 can't you
yeah i mean rent is super expensive
around here but
um but you're running your household on
90 aren't you
am yeah but what i've noticed is a lot
of my co-workers they
basically go by the goal of spending all
of your base salary and then with the
bonus
they save that yeah well i don't agree
with that part but
uh but so but i i think the budget is
fairly easy we can lay your budget out
on your salary and that's your monthly
budget
and basically go on every dollar or join
ramsey plus for a free trial and get
to get the every dollar premium and
that's the world's best budgeting app
it's a very very robust
killer budgeting app to get help you
spend every dollar
of your 90 000 monthly on paper
before the month begins in the app
you're going to give every dollar an
assignment
every dollar a name now then what are we
going to do with the bonus well we're
not going to
uh save that and blow everything else in
in your budget you save and operate your
household
then when you get extra money in your
case once a year you get this big budget
big bonus before the bonus comes i want
you to spend it
on paper also because a month before you
get it you know what it's going to be
don't you
so you know 30 days from now i'm going
to get 60 grand right
yeah okay so i want you to get you can
just get a yellow pad out if you want
and say i'm going to spend 60 000 here
on paper now by spending it i mean
we have to allocate for taxes if they're
not taking taxes out
we have to we're going to put some in
savings we're going to be generous with
some of it be giving
we're going to uh spend some of it on
fun
we're going to pay some debt down we're
going to hit some of the baby steps that
we've been wanting to hit
and some of these other things but every
dollar always
needs an assignment on any money before
it gets there
now if you don't know what the budget is
or let's say you're thinking about this
in september before you know what the
number is going to be in december
then you would start to just make a list
and say okay if i if i don't get as much
as i did last year
what's the most important thing i'm
going to do
and you prioritize the things on this
yellow pad from most important to least
important and you go as far
down that list as the money allows you
to go
when you run out of money on that list
it should be
that you've done the most important
things to you
before you did the least important
things to you because you had a
progressively important list a list that
is listed from most important to least
important with a dollar amount beside it
how far down that list can i go and it
can be
i want to take a trip to europe and i
put a dollar amount beside it i want to
buy a car i put a dollar amount beside i
don't pay off this student loan i put a
dollar amount beside it
i want to finish up baby step three and
have an emergency fund of three to six
months six
expenses and i put a dollar amount
beside it wherever you are whatever your
goals are now which one of those
is the most important is number one and
any minds left over can go to number two
and any months left over can go to
number three and it's a prioritized
spending plan now for those of you that
get have an irregular income monthly
like for instance i grew up in the real
estate business and you really do not
necessarily know what you're going to
make next month
i mean you may have some closings in the
hopper you may have some contracts that
are coming at you but you don't know
exactly what you're going to make next
month
so you really are going to live that
list out
in the coming 30 days so rent
electricity food
it starts if you're going from if you
have zero that you can count on if
you're 100 commission
like that situation yeah you'd start
with food and then you do utilities
and then you do food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities you know
take care of those first and then we're
going to do baby steps
and then we're going to reduce debt and
then we're going to do this and then
we're going to do that
um and you know we're not paying
property taxes before we buy food you
know we're going to decide
if i can only buy one thing what would i
buy that and if i could only buy one
more thing what would i buy
and you list it out like that it makes
you really prioritize your life
the psychology of getting a 60 000 check
on a friday
man you could blow that and i like the
idea of being intentional before you're
holding that money yeah you got to do it
on paper before the money comes
because it's it's gone it's just those
of us that were in the real
real estate business or other straight
commission things you know we
you know we have you know we go from uh
you know buying cadillac's to having
them towed i mean you know it's back and
forth it's all over this volatility
and uh you have this tendency in that
world not her
but if you're in that kind of a world a
sales world in particular
you have this tendency to think you can
out earn your stupidity
and i tried to out earn my stupidity for
years and i was a lot more stupid than i
was talented so
uh i couldn't do it and it kept catching
me and well even if you're not stupid
the world is still spinning around you
there's always something that wants your
money somebody else might be stupid and
cause yeah
there's always something coming at you
you can just count on it it's just
part of the dad blame equation it's how
it works
so that's a great question great
question thank you for joining us we
appreciate you being a listener
good for you killing it melissa that's
fantastic yeah that's a wonderful income
dr john deloney ramsey personality my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt no matter what your goals
are the army national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they will remake your
window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey you know
sometimes i do stuff and i go you're an
idiot like when i mismeasure i screw up
the line
the the window blinds and they remake
them for free even though i'm an idiot
so this is like an idiot proof guarantee
that's pretty cool that's why they call
it ramsey i'm just kidding
you gave me that one man oh underhand
piss yeah yeah all right all right so
today's question comes from annalee in
nevada
emily writes i'm trying to get my
boyfriend and i out of debt
i only owe 28 000 in student loans
my boyfriend has almost eight times more
debt than i do but he thinks you can't
make money without spending it
how do i make him see that he's hurting
himself
run get a new point run
[Laughter]
you can go left to california or right
to all the other states but
run you you can't
um so here's a rule of thumb when dating
do not date people you have to fix yes
or don't when you're in a relationship
and your thought is i have to
get us to that's the that's the problem
because us has to get us to
right his job is to initiate being a
grown-up
thus far he has not done that
yeah and he's not he's i mean it's not
rare that people think
you gotta spend a whole bunch of money
to make money and what i know that's
common so
i don't say he's an idiot he thinks you
can't make money without spending it
right you got to spend money to make
money no he just says
you have to spend all the money you make
oh okay i always think she's in congress
no because there's been more than that
yeah there's been more than they might
yeah
apparently he does too so in
what you can do in elise you can sit
down and and show him math
and you can tell him hey look i love you
and you hurt yourself
then the important part of that
conversation is is one that you're gonna
have to decide
are you in are you out and um you can't
help him
you can't fix him you can't heal him
he's gonna have to be a part of that
journey and you're gonna have to decide
do i want to walk with this guy through
his journey or not um but you can't get
you and your boyfriend out of debt no
you can only get you out of debt and you
can show him how he gets him
out of debt so um
from a relationship perspective not a
financial perspective
if you are my daughter and i have grown
daughters that are married
i would say you'd sit down with this guy
and say
number one cause of divorce in north
america's money fights and money
problems
the fact that we're not in agreement on
this subject is going to end our
relationship
um because i don't think i can make a
life with a guy who can't be responsible
with money
and so i in order for us to go forward
i'm gonna have to see you
become responsible with money i'd be
your cheerleader
i can give you some input i can show you
some things to do
i cannot do it for you nor will i do it
for you
nor will we be together long term if you
are not engaging in growing up
and that's a conversation from emily to
her boyfriend the conversation emily has
to have with anna lee
is i'm reading the tea leaves here but
this is somebody who struggles with
codependency this is someone who
struggles with
an identity that her value comes from
fixing other people
and i want emily to do her work on
herself
and grow her value from the inside out
let that shine to the world because it
because we need her voice out there and
then she's going to attract people who
are not projects that are not
puzzles and they're not engines who are
missing spark plugs
it's just an amazing way people attract
what they put out in the world
right let me ask you something i i don't
disagree with that uh
you know you tend to um
it's not the victim's fault that someone
is a victim but there's even been
studies shown that a rapist will pick
a the way someone walks you just feel it
yeah they're
predators they're they're a predator and
they sense weakness
and they sense the body language in
other words and so
um you know and that's what you're
saying her body language is she has this
tendency to try to fix things and so she
takes in strays kind of thing um
and let's pretend for a second that it's
not that okay
that this is and we don't know her but
but just for the sake of uh argument
with our audience because we've got a
lot of audience in their early 20s
late teens especially on youtube and
um let's pretend that this is a 19 year
old young woman
okay and um
maybe she does feel okay about herself
but she just really likes this guy
and before she know it she's kind of in
love with him and then he has this
problem
yeah and he's a great guy and except
four
except for and he and this is not like
you know normally she would not be taken
in straight normally she would not be
lacking in self-esteem normally she
would not be there
but she just kind of you know this guy's
they they've built a relationship but
and then all of a sudden she realizes oh
god this guy's got issues
so i i was a little different than i i'm
attracting oh yes yeah
so because i i have a pattern of always
you know bringing home losers yeah i
read this quote this weekend that
i was sitting on my front porch reading
dave and i stopped and it said sometimes
you have to have the courage to break
your own heart because it's the right
thing to do
and sometimes you've got to do something
so hard that's
the parent that says you cannot bring
drugs back into my home
yeah that is the girlfriend that says i
love you and
you're gonna drown us both and i'm not
going to not
i'm not going to sign up for this
because this is going to be a long
horrible life
right and so this idea the the courage
and bravery it takes to say
i love you and i value
my ability to breathe but anali if
you're that person i'm talking about
not the one john was talking about a
minute ago that you're generally fairly
uh self-confident you need to know that
your
desire for love in this particular
situation has flipped your language
out of the abundance of the heart the
mouth speaks your language says
codependence all over it
you know so let me kind of go back my
boyfriend has almost 8 million times
more debt than i do
but he thinks you can't make money
without spending it how do i make him
see he's hurting himself i'm trying to
get my boyfriend and i
out of debt yeah you me i'm going to fix
him i'm going to fix him i'm going to
fix him as what i says over and over and
over again
and there's a guy over there with a
backhoe digging holes and you've got
your shovel and you're like how do i
how do i fill it up and faster than he
can dig it up he can dig it faster than
you that's right yeah you're digging out
the bottom faster than you're ever going
to get there so i want you to put that
shovel down and go get some give you a
high probability on this annaleigh
um as the old guy the that's a walking
dead joke
okay high probability is
that if you are a one young woman of
confidence
and a good self-esteem uh that this
young man is not going to change fast
enough to keep you around
you're going to move on because i don't
think he's marriage material
i know he's not marriage material today
and it's because john
opened up with run that was his opening
answer
was run and and i like to think of these
calls as what do i do if
josephine comes home from college and
says that i found a guy
right yeah and dave you may not have
experienced this
and that's me being sarcastic i'm sure
you did but sheila had people sit down
and
and talk to her like are you sure you
know what you're doing with him
right um like they would take her out
kept sharing away from those
oh man they found sheila are you sure
and she's like i'm sure
um her parents had to be rolling their
eyes when they when i walked in i
wouldn't let my daughter date me
not in a million years oh man i don't
even go down that road
but so there is that right but but um
but sharon did not take me on as a
project no and i'd take her on as a
project
we were both projects but we didn't take
each other everybody right but yes
sheila did not get her self-esteem by
saying i'm gonna fix john right yeah
it's just good parenting to run those
guys off if you have the opportunity
you know i'm just like daddy all the
boys in the youth group are scared of
you and i went good
keeps away two things wusses and jerks
don't need either one dating my daughter
that keeps away more than it keeps away
everything
wusses and jerks pretty well you put
most things in those two buckets
they're the same bucket well you know
there's some time at times
sometimes but it's just run and lee run
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsay show open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five john and ashley
are with us in new hampshire it says on
my screen you guys are
debt-free congratulations thank you
thank you
well done how much have you paid off 75
000. all right how long did this take 11
months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
105 to 120 000. cool what do you guys do
for a living
uh we work for your friends at the kgb
actually
okay cool hey that that admittedly took
me a second because
of anyone in my life who would actually
know the real kgb it'd probably be dave
so it took me a second but i got it now
i got the irs yes yes the uh the phone
calls that i take with
individuals that owe balances are a lot
different now i educate
a lot now well thank you thank you
that's very good so tell us your story
what kind of debt was this
we had and one auto loan but it was
multiple
upside downs wrapped into one so it was
like a 650 dollar
payment for one auto loan yes
student loans we financed our bed
we had a best buy card for the washer
and dryer
um and that was it the way you said we
financed our bed
so we just kept getting heard him make
fun of people for doing that before
you finessed what yeah mm-hmm yeah well
yeah haven't we all and and so how long
have you guys been married
uh a little over three years okay so
what happened 11 months ago what was the
turning point
uh it's uh well we were on our way to
make another
bad financial decision we were going to
our credit union to ask about their
40-year mortgage offer
and then they told us that we could sit
down with
a financial advisor because we were
members so we got an hour
and he said uh you guys have a bad debt
to
income ratio so maybe hold off on that
oh when the bank won't take your money
that's when you know you got a problem
right
yeah so i mean i went home after
speaking with him and
you know just did what most people do
just checked out videos on youtube and
uh the algorithm hit you know dave
ramsey videos and i don't know i
spent probably the next two weeks just
analyzing and
analyzing until i finally brought it to
ashley's attention she was like why'd
you wait so long let's go let's do this
ah okay we bought a pu right after that
and
it was kind of you know hit the ground
running
just go game on when the when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
huh
exactly yeah the app said it was going
to take 20 months and we did it in 11.
yeah well that's because you decide to
do it all and do it all
with a game on attitude i'm proud of you
mess with irs issues
they will get it done did you flashy
thing me yeah
oh man you guys that's impressive so
well done
so what do you now that you did it now
that you're successful
you've successfully got out of debt
something congress can't do
what uh what would you tell people the
key to getting out of that ass
budget for sure we thought we were only
going to have a hundred dollars extra
a month to put it the debt and when we
did the budget we found
two thousand dollars that we could put
towards the budget without overtime
wow yes and saying no we have three
young kids
so we learned quickly to say no
okay and they didn't they didn't die
they didn't
they run away they didn't leave you
they're not in counseling yeah
right no no they're they're perfectly
fine they're happy with it actually
we explained to them what we were doing
and they loved watching
the colors of the uh car loan
you know getting higher with us paying
it off they would come in and check
every day and they'd get mad at us if it
didn't
you know go down wow turned it into a
game
yeah yeah they were our biggest
cheerleaders that's fun
good for you guys well it sounds like
there's a lot of transformation happened
in the house during this time
yes for sure so talk to me about that
drive home
with your head held low to
that husband who's like man i gotta
figure this out to how's your marriage
now
um well communication um is
obviously the way that we both work
there i mean everyone
like critiques us for like or just ask
you know how do you spend 24 7 with each
other
um you know and do all and it's because
of the communication and
you know we tackled it together you know
for sure so um i
am the numbers guy and i just i would
sit there and
crunch and crunch but she just would
make it work she took over with the
budget we'd have the meetings and
you know she'd sit in there and do the
transactions and
so it's just the the constant
communication back and forth the
teamwork
the precisely i love it well done you
guys
very well done i'm so proud of you so
um this is an interesting thing i want
to follow the thread through
you meet with the financial advisor at
the credit union he says you have too
high a debt to income ratio
meaning you is broke and you come home
spend a couple of weeks pouring over
youtube videos that leads you into
financial peace university
what do you feel like looking back on
that journey you've been through was the
core
message that you got from us that caused
you to be able to do this
to me preparing for the future
um you know kind of like dr john said
you know me hanging my head down though
like how do i
figure this out well that was just for
us to try to
get out of you know my parents home with
three kids we were living with
my parents and you know i was like how
can i
you know fix this you know with what it
was my student loans and
you know that was one of the biggest
problems um
but you know it was just
you know pushing through and um you know
looking forward to the ability to set
them up
educate them so that they don't make the
same mistakes that i do
um so it's kind of like you're more
willing to sacrifice when you have a
higher calling something other than just
i want to back rep
mine was the give part yeah being able
to get to the point where i couldn't
give back
yeah that was the biggest thing for me
other than setting my kids up for
success but yeah
but change your family tree and
generosity are non-selfish
noble higher calling goals
versus i want to buy a nice car exactly
and by the way you can do both you don't
have to they're not mutually exclusive
but
but i want to buy a nice car someday
isn't enough motivation to sacrifice
i want to change my kids lives you can
sacrifice
the six-year-old's already saving for a
tesla
because he's not going to borrow money
from the bank he said he's going gonna
pay for it now i like this guy
when he's 55 he'll have earned that
money to afford that car
he's got like 200 already he'll have
more than elon has himself so there you
go
i love it congratulations you guys we're
so proud of you we got a copy of rachel
cruz's book for you her latest new york
times bestseller
it's called know yourself know your
money you guys are an impressive couple
thank you so much for sharing your story
with us
john and ashley from new hampshire 75
000 paid off in 11 months making 105
to 120. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
i think i heard that family tree joining
in man that's the way it's supposed to
be
the roots called that on that one that's
the way the sound that's the way this
the sound of a family tree changing
right there
when that you get that chipmunk voice
going in there with it that's that's
when you know you're on
on track baby man that gives me
goosebumps when i hear the kids yelling
it's fun stuff uh that means they were
plugged in they were dialed in they knew
what was going on and that's
uh sophia they got it on our screen here
sophia jackson and grayson were joining
in there so
congratulations they got to watch mom
and dad do hard things
and they learned hey we can do hard
things
and i man there's something about
growing up in a deffered house that's a
legacy shift there's something about
giving your kid
you know a car and a house and paid for
a college that's cool
there's also something about letting
your kids watch you struggle and learn
and go
heard no no and they think
powerful words i can do hard stuff
yeah mom and dad can do hard stuff i can
do hard stuff
love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you ever ask questions like how much
should i be
saving or how do i get out of that
faster
or what's the right way to invest or
i don't know where to learn about money
well here's the good news you don't have
to figure all this out on your own
ramsey plus
will guide you every step of the way
with a ramsey plus membership you get
all the digital teaching in financial
peace university and
other classes you need to really
understand money so you can be
confident you're always doing the next
right thing the budgeting app
every dollar is pretty amazing the tools
the guided action steps
they help you make progress on your
money goals really really fast and that
means
no more debt cash in the bank for
emergencies
a real plan for your future a sense of
peace and power around your money
ramsay plus helps you get small
consistent wins
every day that cause you to have the big
results
and the lifelong habit change you get
started today with a free trial text
trial at 33 789
text trial 233 789
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
john is with us in atlanta hi john
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave
thanks for having me
sure how can we help well dave i'm
calling in because i'm 27 years old
i've got a stable job with the federal
government that pays pretty well
and i'm just kind of looking forward
at my future here and it seems like
a lot of the people who stay in this
position
kind of end up losing passion for what
they do
and i'm starting to notice myself losing
passion for what i do
and so you know when i bring this up
with my family they kind of tell me
you should stick with it you've got a
pension there um you know you've got
ironclad job security but i feel like
if i stay here i'm gonna i'm gonna go
crazy all right i wanted to know
i'm 27. long you been there man
two years how many two years
two and what is it you do exactly daily
um well i work as a statistician so
basically i'm you know they try to
automate a lot of the things that my
organization does now
and so i'm involved with that
what do you love doing man
well um i i do love
working with numbers i do love um
statistics it's what i studied in school
why is this driving me crazy then
well it's driving me crazy because i
just don't uh
i don't know it just doesn't seem like
the people who work here are very
passionate about what they do
i mean um yeah you're
i don't let us don't care about them for
a second what about you
it's okay to be in a room where you like
what you're doing even if the people
around you don't
um no because the problem sorry the
problem is that
what a lot of the times what ends up
happening is that if you're passionate
you know you end up getting extra work
but because of the way the system works
there's not really
there's not really much advancement so
it just becomes frustrating
what what does the word passionate mean
to you
i've been hearing my students use that
word passionate for years
now what what does that mean to you
well i suppose that what it means is
that sometimes
you know if you wake up in the morning
and you don't want to do something
and it's okay to feel like that
sometimes
but if you feel like that day after day
after day
um then that means that you lack passion
so passion means that
i guess over a long period of time you
can look back at what you've done and
say
you know i really enjoyed doing that
that really
that really made me feel like i was
doing something important
good answer okay so what's the downside
with you going to work someplace else
well i would lose i would lose my job
security for one thing
you don't have any job security there's
no such thing you work for the federal
government brother
yeah they lay people off today
they lay people off too they're probably
not gonna go broke i don't think
but um but they lay people off too and
your job you're only as secure as your
ability to do things that people want to
pay you for
and if you're a statistician who likes
statistics you're going to be
employable for a long time in a
data-driven world
yeah this whole world's driven off of
data right now and you're a data analyst
if there ever was one right
right yeah i mean i suppose that you
probably can make twice as much money
yeah if not three times yeah i'm sure
yeah i'm sure it's just a you know
security
security is an illusion dude it's a drug
brother yeah you need to get out of
there
um because i mean you're 27 years old
project this out you're going to be 57
30
years of doing this you already sound
old right now
i can't imagine how long you'll sound
then that's a great line i was trying to
think what he's not depressed but you
just sound old man
you sound 74. yeah you know can you
imagine how old you're going to be when
you're 57.
good god you'll be a thousand
in government years you're total
government employee years yeah
hey listen the people around you the
people who
who are giving you advice um they mean
well but they're just wrong
they yeah they are telling you they love
you in the only language they know how
which is
you being safe and you be insecure which
we know is an illusion but they're
doing the best they can with what they
got and at some point you've got to get
off the drug of
safety get off the illusion of safety
and jump so john one of my heroes was my
grandpa
in the great depression uh he was 27
years old oddly enough and he
in the in the stock market crash he lost
a business and went
and went broke and alcoa aluminum had
come to alcoa tennessee
in the hills of east tennessee and
opened a plant and he went to work for
them
he worked there 38 years and never left
because of the fear
partly because of the fear of uh having
gone broke when he was young
and partly because he was a good man and
wanted to provide for his family
and the stability of that was there in
that environment my grandmother became
really dependent upon that security that
you're talking about
and uh humorous story uh the first time
i sold my millionth
book i've sold about 20 million now
about the time i sold my millionth book
which means i had made
millions and millions of dollars okay if
you can imagine
my grandmother called and still was
worried about me
running my own little business when you
get a real job dave that's exactly what
she said
she called up and said honey i'm worried
about you when are you going to get a
real job and i had just sold my
millionth book
now she's sweet and i understood where
she was coming from because i know the
story
and my grandpa was my hero and i
understand
he's just one of my favorite people that
i ever knew on this planet
i miss him greatly to this day but the
uh
and i loved her i loved her too as well
she's sweet as she could be
but in her that was her love language
from the environment and the situation
the way they had lived life
was to say when are you gonna get a real
job and she meant well
uh john just like the people in your
life mean well but i just sold a million
bucks so i think we can safely say the
data the statistical evidence is that
she was wrong
okay and here's the thing if you go out
on your own
and you give it three four years and it
doesn't work
my guess is you could probably get a job
get your job right back
that's right maybe not that exact one
with that exec department or whatever
but whoop-dee-doop-dee
uh you you have a marketable skill in a
data-driven world
data is the businesses that don't
understand grasp and harness the data
the power of data
in the next decade we'll be out of
business correct it's not optional so
you are a highly sought after
individual in your world and so that
that's
um i'm telling you i think you're
probably making about half or maybe a
fourth of what you're worth
and you're giving it all up in the name
of security that's not really there
anyway
get out yeah you can just hear i can
hear your soul leaking it out
it's leaking out of your body out yeah
get out get out
get out yeah there's something there's
something to be said for i want you to
be safe
and so i want you to drown slowly right
i want you to be safe well i don't think
everyone should be an entrepreneur no
absolutely i don't think everyone should
be on straight commission i don't mean
that
but you know you're only as secure as
your own ability to land the next thing
because you have talent
yeah and people want to work with you
yeah yeah
marketable skills and personality and
so forth that's your that's your only
real security because everything else is
smoke and mirrors the guy making the
payroll he's
he's scared too yeah and you think
you're secure
that's funny you know this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
jennifer starts off this hour in
washington d.c hi jennifer welcome to
the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so my husband will be retiring from the
coast guard next summer
summer 2022 and we plan to move back
home to colorado springs
so we currently have 150 000 down
for a home to purchase and the question
that we have is
because the market is just crazy right
now and homes are flying
you know off the market and 20 to 50 000
over asked
should we start the process now knowing
that we're not going to pay over asking
um you know should we start looking at
houses now and then buying something
and just letting it set empty if we end
up buying something or should we just
wait until we actually get out there
and we also don't have any jobs lined up
yet either
how long has he been serving um it'll be
22 years next summer
my goodness well tell him thanks for his
service we appreciate it and you too you
guys have moved all over the world
haven't you
um yeah we have thank you yeah i'm glad
you're settling in it's good it's a good
it's a good time of life for you
and you're gonna have a nice and i think
i'm also a little bit i have i think i
have house fever because we've been
renting for so long
yeah you've got you've got kind of a
nesting instinct kicking in
almost here it's like finally i get to
get my place
and i'm wanting to do it and all these
people went crazy with their houses
after coving and they're messing up my
plan
yes yeah i don't blame you i get i get
where you are
i don't disagree um so
the only reason you would go ahead and
do all of that now
is if you believe that this white hot
crazy upbid market is going to continue
for 12 to 18 months i personally don't
think it's going to continue at this
fever pitch this fever pitch is is the
is the other end of the the other side
of the coin
of covid freezing the entire economy
shut
because everybody stayed home and they
were frederkovic was going to get on
them and
and so they stayed home the government
told them to stay home they stayed home
and it shut the economy down
and then all this pent up demand it's
like the whole economy held its breath
it's like holding a hose right yeah all
the whole economy held its breath and it
finally sticks his head up above water
and goes
and that's what he's doing and so i
think it's you know just like if you
come out of the pool
after being on the bottom of the pool
yeah you can get your breath trying to
get your breath
you know your you're you're
hyperventilating almost and then within
10 minutes what happens
kind of everything levels off and quote
you know calms down and and that's what
i think is going to happen with housing
so i don't think that that this this
hose being
pinched and then released or you know
breath being held at the bottom of the
pool and then
finally released is going to be the
continued
version of the economy for the next five
years uh i don't know
net net net if the house prices are
going to end up higher
or not honestly colorado springs has
been a very hot market for a very long
time
and so it's going to be a tough market
in terms of buying a house
but the uh you know of course you've got
a huge military presence there
spoken on the base there and so there's
always going to be some housing turnover
because of that
uh but it's it's a highly desirable city
to live in
and quality of life and you know
lifestyle and everything and so
um and so there's always been a lot of
activity around it as long as i can
remember
uh it's been a strong market uh but i i
don't
know so all of that to say
i think the feelings you're having are
natural
especially given your situation uh
but but i wouldn't worry about it i just
wait till you get out
go out there get your jobs if you rent
for a year
to do the right thing it's not going to
kill you and by then i think this
hyperventilating market is going to get
back to a normal breathing pattern
of some kind does that make sense
yeah it definitely makes sense i think i
just need an outside perspective to calm
me down
yeah your instincts are right on both
ends right you know
this is put out a good time to buy and
i gotta buy something right now right
yeah i think you you accurately
accurately uh diagnosed yourself
[Laughter]
which is good news self-awareness is
always a sign of mental of good mental
health there's only like 18 people in
the country that have that so
good for you and and not many of them
are in washington dc so you're a real
rarity
[Laughter]
she won't be for long going to colorado
springs yeah she's leaving yeah
get out while the getting's good uh yeah
thank you for your service again i
appreciate you i would just be calm
and uh while all about you have lost
their head
you keep your head and just just go this
is what's right
this is what's right and there's no
better place to be cool off
i'm going to have an end breathe and an
outbreak pile of cash too a rhythm
with a big 150 000 bucks in my right
hand and i'm just going to sit here and
breathe a little bit yeah that's a good
floaty right yeah
that's a good floaty on the pool pool
metaphor here
it's gonna beat this metaphor to death
yeah yeah just wear it out
all right david is with us david's in
kalamazoo michigan hey david what's up
hi guys thanks for taking my call um
also thank you for the every dollar app
that thing that we we love it well thank
you
so my question today is i listen to your
podcast all the time i don't think i've
ever heard you talk about
works oh how irp
because i don't because i wouldn't ever
tell anybody to do one
can you kind of explain i haven't got a
good explanation of how it even works or
what the advantage over a wasp
just having a lot well basically it's a
sophisticated version
of cash value life insurance
it's a life insurance retirement plan
lirp
and you're using life insurance as an
investment vehicle
which is the definition of sucks
and um you're using life insurance as an
investment vehicle to create your
retirement plan
it's a horrible right of return it's
very inefficient
and um but the insurance world
it does the very best they can to sell
this garbage and package it up
90 000 different ways and this is yet
one more way they packaged it
and they try to create some kind of
narrative or language around it where
people will continue to be
snuffed by it but basically anytime you
buy life insurance as an investment you
have a bad rate of return
and often most often the way that the
deals are structured is when you die
the money you have in the investment is
built into the insurance
they pay out the insurance and keep the
investment and it just never works out
that's the typical whole life policy
that's a variable life policy that's a
indexed universal policy a double
backflip
circus policy i mean they just make up
crap you know and
you know so it's it's really
anytime you hear investing in life
insurance there's one word you need to
remember run
buy life insurance for death only do
your investing in real investments
don't buy your mufflers at the
transmission store
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show if there's one
thing
we all need to know by now it's that you
cannot
invest alone you need someone in your
life who knows the market better than
you is in it every day and helps you
make
smart decisions to respond to it look i
love do-it-yourselfers i'm a
do-it-yourselfer but i don't pull my own
teeth
and i don't work on my own cars anymore
i don't even know what they do when i
lift the hood it doesn't even look like
anything i used to turn a wrench on
25 years ago they're completely
different and i would tear it up
tear up a perfectly good car with uh
that or
i probably would mess up my dental work
where to do it myself so
i actually bring in professionals now
do i take everything that everyone says
and believe
a hundred percent of it no i expect them
to teach me
if the mechanic comes out and says you
need to spend a thousand dollars i want
to know why
i want to know what's broken and how it
works and what are we going to do to fix
it i don't want just
oh yeah they just tell you what to do i
don't when a doctor says
you know you have this and i'm like well
what's that mean you're gonna have to
teach me
you know the tax guy says you need to do
this i'm like i don't do it blindly i
want to know why
i want to know why i'm that little boy
eight-year-old boy why why why why why
which is how you properly invest by the
way
you don't just throw your money at some
dude in a suit or some lady in a dress
and go
take care of my money and then walk out
the door and hope it works out it won't
this is how people lose their money so
you get someone in your corner and you
ask
why and how and they have the heart of a
teacher
and they will walk you through the right
kind of a process
this is how you become wealthy oh and by
the way
when you're scared or you're worried
about the economy or the news
comes on and says the stock market
dropped today and that you're like oh no
i've just lost all my retirement no you
didn't
call and talk to your advisor and
they'll talk to you about the history of
market fluctuations
and how life really works and they'll
talk you off the ledge and let your
little emotions calm down and then you
can continue to invest
because the only one that gets hurt on a
roller coaster are those that jump off
in the middle of the freaking ride
so you need someone like a smart vester
pro with that heart of a teacher
and that experience and that know-how
to show you what you understand so you
can invest
and stay invested text the word invest
to 33
789 that's texting invest
to 33789 and we'll create a rock solid
investing plan with one of our smart
vester pros today
they don't work for us but these are men
and women across the nation in your
neighborhood
that i proudly endorse they are trusted
by ramsey alicia is with us in orlando
hi alicia welcome to the dave ram after
the ramsey show with dr
john dolone how are you hi good
afternoon sirs thank you so much for
um giving me some hopefully a great
financial advice
we'll try um i've had a hit
very bad financial history and it's
taken me over
12 years to get out from where i was and
i am fearful of repeating history
so after all my expenses are
taken care of each month i have an
additional 4 000
that i don't know what to do with wow
look at you yeah it's it's been
long to get out of it so wait
let's talk about it a minute what was
what's your income
but um i earn 150 every year what do you
do
oh i work in insurance you're amazing
well done
very well done so uh you said it's been
a long shlog
out of the mess how long did it take you
to get out of the mess
uh just over about 10 years
was it an income mess you didn't have a
good income or was it uh
you did stupid mistakes very stupid
mistakes i was um
one of millions of people that were
caught up in the 2008 housing market
and i bought a house i couldn't afford
and it's just it was ever since then
i could not get out of it and i'm
finally at a place
when did you get out of there i
had a short sale and after filing
bankruptcy
2012 was when i finally got out from
under that so from 2012 to today
uh nine years you've been progressively
doing smarter and smarter things and
have not added any dumb things to the
list
no sir that's pretty good you got a
decade of clean
it's been hard i learned my lesson and i
do not want to go there
i've had my car repossessed i've had not
not in nine years you haven't no no that
was all part of yeah i know
downfall of the 2008. let me tell you
what i'm hearing john and i talk about
this a lot let me tell you what i heard
the language you're using you're still
living back there in the pain and the
shame
no shame i'm proud you haven't you
haven't
ought to be very proud you've got a
whole decade of being awesome
oh thank you i'm but i'm scared well i
mean that's okay my wife's scared not we
went broke 30 years ago she still looks
at me like i'm crazy occasionally
and listen all that means is your
brain's working just fine yeah
it's seen how bad things can get and it
never wants to let you do that again and
it's willing
here's the thing it's like you get near
the edge of that cliff you're like no
you can fall
you know your brain we will smoke a
cigarette to calm down today
and it will kill us tomorrow all our
brain wants to do is take care of us
right this second so as soon as you
start seeing this money and you start
thinking about it
it conjures up all the old to keep you
in the straight and narrow
but that can rob you of joy and fun and
all of the rewards of this stuff
you've worked so hard for what i want
you to hear is is i'm talking to a lady
that makes 150
000 a year and has made good financial
decisions for a decade you know what
that makes you
a freaking unicorn you're unusually
awesome
you're incredible um it's just
learning from where i don't want to be
again that was
my only driving force yeah listen the
next phase is to
not run from things but to run tucson
yeah and listen
when your brain tries to protect you it
means everything's working great and all
you have to say is
thanks for checking in i'm doing great i
make 150 grand
brain and i don't make stupid decisions
anymore brain
and then you feel free to share your
life with other people and man you are
off to the races alicia
okay so what we need to do is we need to
assign
a task that is future oriented because
the past
has passed that's future oriented to
these four thousand dollars a month that
you have
and so are you single yes do you own a
home
yes okay how much do you owe on it
uh well i think it's roughly around
4 20 now okay and what do you
do you have any other debt no sir
and you have how much saved
um so i have no retirement savings
i have my six month emergency fund of
30 000. good and you've heard us talk
about the baby steps where you put
at this stage you are at baby step four
and you put
my first time across you guys i'm so
sorry
it's all right you have your emergency
fund and you're debt-free but the house
that brings you to what we call baby
step four which is 15
of your income going into retirement
five is kids college i don't think that
applies in your situation
and baby step six is pay off your house
early so we're gonna put 15 percent of
your income
into retirement that's gonna be twenty
two thousand five hundred dollars in
your life
per year about two thousand dollars a
month going into retirement
and then everything above that that you
have free you're either going to spend
it
and or throw it as extra payments on the
house to pay off the house early
and my estimation is is that as your
income continues to grow you're going to
pay off this house in under 10 years
from where you are and you're going to
be in a very amazing place with your
retirement 10 years from today
because you start saving 22 000 a year 2
000 a month
24 000 a year somewhere in there you're
going to be rocking it kiddo
and so your future is bright because
of what you learned in the past and i
don't want
any listener to blow by dave's wisdom
here
when the gazelle takes off he's running
or she is running from a lion
and when that when that threat is over
then that that gazelle has to go towards
friends it's got to go towards the new
watering source towards new green grass
it's got to go to stuff not always just
keep sprinting and spreading sprinting
yeah you can only run away from things
so long you start out you need to run
two things this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
kwashira is with us hey kashira how are
you hi dave hi john
welcome where do you live i live in
charlotte north carolina welcome to
nashville and all the way over here to
do a debt-free scream
yes sir how much you pay off 82 thousand
dollars
and how long did this take 26 months wow
and your range of income during that
time
i started at 56 000 and last year i
grossed
122. whoa yes you doubled your income
i did in two years yes well first i have
to hear how you did that
i took a leap of faith and i took
another career path and now i'm a
mortgage loan officer so
pretty much where were you before a
premier banker
so doing credit cards yes so you took
you took the private banking knowledge
the premier banking knowledge
and you how to serve clients
particularly high-end clients roll into
the mortgage business and go
touchdown absolutely perfect timing what
a time to get into the mortgage business
yeah
and what a time to take that skill set
and use it well done
well done i love it what kind of debt
was the 82 000
well i financed a iphone security system
i had to pay taxes i took out a 401k
loan to put
money down on a house i bought i had two
car notes i had to buy my mom a car she
just had to have a car right
in my opinion um so small credit card
debt
and the largest one was 52 000 student
loans
god you just did everything yes i mean
you're like normal
pretty normal plus a little a little
extra normal on there correct
hey and here's what makes all of this
ironic you worked for a bank
yes i do work for a bank you knew better
yeah well
yeah no she was telling people do the
same stuff all day exactly there you go
yeah so uh what what happened
it changed all this yeah it's a few
things i was talking to one of my
supervisors
and just a little jim he asked me how
much did i have in my savings and i told
him
about three or four thousand at the time
he said how much debt do you have and i
was just counting the student loans i
said fifty three thousand dollars
he was like well you don't have a
savings so i was like okay that makes
sense i feel like that sparked it and
then somehow i really don't remember how
but i came across your book i read it
and then i
i went down a loophole of watching debt
free screams
and there was this one particular story
where this lady she was single like
myself
she made the same amount of money she
paid off the same amount of debt i'm
like if she could do it i surely can do
it yeah
i took off from there and now somebody's
watching you yes
yeah and they're gonna do it because you
did that i hope so thank you
thank you you're very inspiring very
very fun
82 026 months
yes so you read the book and then you
went down the rabbit hole of youtube and
watched um
because there's thousands of debt free
screams on youtube i mean we've got
we've got them all on our
youtube channel about a billion
downloads on on the podcast now
and literally and so people are doing
this all the time
yes uh and what a good i mean you just
like that just fills up your spirit yes
other people winning yelling
yeah that's cool that's going to be me
yeah yeah what was the first thing you
actually did then
with this new motivation yeah i am i'm a
very goal oriented person i like to see
things on paper so i wrote down all of
my debt
and my goal was just to be debt free by
30. i started this when i was 26
so four years was plenty enough time but
of course
you know our lord and savior sped that
up it just kept things just kept lining
up where
income increasing checks were coming you
know i took on extra jobs
etc so just got accurate yeah i've
watched this for years and i've um
the anal or the metaphor that i've used
is that it's like god is sitting up
there going
oh look there's one that's now smart i
can trust this one
because when you're faithful with the
little things you're given more to
manage that's scriptural
and it's almost as if you're walking
along and you step up on one of those
moving sidewalks at the airport
and now you're still walking but you're
moving even faster yes
and like god just takes you faster than
your little legs to take you by yourself
absolutely he let me finish this a month
after well actually the same month i
turned 29 so
again he fast tracked my plan yeah his
plans was always better than ours so
you're faster hey man you're faster than
you thought you were going to correct
yeah way to go thank you who is your
biggest cheerleader
um you know my family is always going to
support me but outside of that i feel
like just watching
listening to your show daily i mean i
would take roaches i would listen to on
the plane
um i did uber and lift for his time i
would play it in the car so just
keeping you on and again just watching
youtube videos kept me motivated
with the listeners looking to do what
i'm doing when did you make the jump to
mortgages
july of 2019 and i finished july 2020.
okay so one year of the two years was at
a
potentially higher income correct or a
higher income certainly you've been i'm
sure the mortgage business has gotten
better every month
after they're doing this yeah and um and
you did all this through covid
correct which was great for me a lot of
folks are taking advantage of
not having to pay student loans and i
thought it was a great opportunity to
pay student loans since
all my money is going towards principal
versus interest so of course
again guess just gazelle that as well
yeah very what was it what was
give us a moment you got scared things
things got dicey
um it's a long journey um you know i
tell any anyone it's
it's one of the hardest things i ever
did it's simple and i need simple
a simple plan to follow but was one of
the hardest things i ever did so
just just trying to stick with it and
just remembering hey this is temporary
this is going to be two years and i'm
only 29 i have my entire life
to live financially free so when it got
scary you just backed up and had
perspective
correct remember remembering the goal
yeah and remember where i'm gonna be
what you're gonna feel like exactly
yeah that's a big deal that's very
strong
that's very strong you're an amazing
young woman i'm so proud of you thank
you
i'm sure your mom's proud of you she
came with you who else came with yes my
mom and my sister
all right family is supporting yes i
like it this is very very cool
well congratulations thank you so much
very well done so you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is yeah
so um stay the course
again it may get wary but just stick
with it you you're literally almost
probably close to
finishing if you thinking about quitting
um lowering your expenses increasing
your income is a big one
i got rid of streaming services um i
went from 120
cell phone bill down to 50. my folks
actually laugh at me because my service
isn't that great but my bill is 50
so and i don't want to talk to you
anyway it's right exactly
after talking on the phone with my
clients um discipline and sacrifice
those are those are the keys for me
we're getting out of debt yeah yeah you
you uh
you really uh
you were so game on i mean you you
identified the target like you said you
said i'm goal oriented but you really
are
you're that's not just that's the way
your brain works and once you set that
thing
and then it's game on correct you know
and there's no stopping you and and
uh did you learn anything about yourself
during this journey
um i would say i can really do whatever
i
really put my mind to you kind of
already knew that yeah
yeah this just gave you more confidence
correct yeah
yeah because you weren't lacking in
confidence before no you you gotta
you gotta meet your mama raise your
right that's awesome yeah you got a
presence about you that's powerful
wow thank you cool well done
yeah well we got a copy of rachel cruz's
latest new york times bestseller know
yourself know your money for you thank
you
i will add that to your collection of
ramsey books and you're an impressive
young woman
well done all right quichera from
charlotte north carolina
82 000 paid off in 26 months
making 56 to 122. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one i'll die free
[Applause]
man oh man oh man oh man
i don't know a lot but when kashira has
a goal i'm not going to get between her
and that goal
no you wouldn't want to no and i don't i
i also don't know a lot but i think you
just got a parenting principle
woven into that that mom taught that kid
how to be that kind of woman how
to have self-worth how to have goals how
to
i to know i can do hard things all of it
you have value and that means you can go
get whatever you'll get zero
chance no that woman's gonna be a victim
nope
she's killed or to adopt a victim
position of any kind ever
do not get in her way that's cool i'm
gonna run right through it
that's incredible it's incredible
because here's mom i see you and you're
inspiring me because i'm raising a
little girl and you're inspiring me
amen yeah i'm gonna build a warrior
princess baby that's how you do it
wow pretty incredible
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture today james 1 4 let
perseverance finish its work
so that you may be mature and complete
not lacking
anything benjamin franklin said
energy and persistence conquer
all things dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about life and about
money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jessica is with us she's in wilmington
north carolina hi jessica
how can we help hi dave hi dr d how are
y'all today
great what's up great um so my husband
and i
are trying to figure out if we can
afford for me to start my career
so just some quick details we re we
recently finished
baby step two i'm working on baby step
three which will probably take us about
five more months um i'm going to be
going into real estate so there are
going to be some
startup um costs associated with that
probably around like
1200 with mls access and
the exams and everything like that but
we will have to
figure out getting child care for our
son
so my husband is in the military we
could utilize the base daycare for about
600 a month but we're wondering if we
should essentially
pause baby step 3 and save the money
for my startup and a few months of child
care to cover that gap in between
when i start and when i get my first
commission check or if we should finish
up baby step three
and then save up for those costs
associated with me
starting work
eighteen hundred dollars takes you
through the first
month twelve hundred dollars worth of
costs and six hundred dollars worth of
daycare right
that should be right yeah okay um
how old are you uh we are both
22 22.
yes okay and have you had discussions
with a real estate broker that you would
go to work for
yes i have i have been in the office
several times to speak with them and
have interest with a particular
brokerage
and what's their training program like
and what do they project before you to
make your first sale
um so they have told me
one of the girls who i've been talking
to she said that it took her
about six weeks to get her first
contract but there are other girls
in the office who um they've
gotten a contract within the first few
weeks and some
longer so that is
what is going to be your delete what's
going to be your lead source
um they i'm not 100
sure still trying to figure out all of
those details
okay um and what does your husband make
a year
um he makes around 40 000 a year
why real estate um it's always something
that i have been
interested in and you know i have
a passion to help people and i figure
um taking my interest and my passion
mixing that together could be a good
idea all right let me
tell you the full picture of what i'm
hearing and what what's also running
through my head
okay and then let's kind of put all that
on the table and we'll start playing
with it and trying to figure out what to
do
i got my real estate license when i
turned 18 years old
um i did sell a house three weeks later
because to one of my high school buddies
because i was just out of high school
which means both of us were pretty
stupid actually
but um i mean who buys a house from an
18 year old except another 18 year old
right so
um but the uh uh or a 19 year old or
something like that i mean this is like
happy days does real estate or something
but the um
uh uh but by and large
uh and i sold real estate actively
all the way through college from 18 to
22 years old
and then and i've had my licenses ever
since
so uh what you're saying can be done
uh i will tell you from experience male
or female
um it is very it's an uphill battle to
have credibility
to get someone to make the largest
purchase that they ever make in their
life with a 22 year old
it's uh it can be done but you're going
to have people that just simply will not
work with you because of your age
because you just don't have credibility
and uh or they're sc you know they like
you you're sweet
uh pat you on the head but won't do but
won't actually close the deal you know
what i'm saying
that's a lot different than the crusty
old uh
you know 56 year old battle axe right um
that just tells everybody what to do and
they do it you know kind of thing it's
you're just in a different position in
your life in terms of credibility so you
need to know that you're
this is not a hot knife through butter
it can be done right but but you got you
got
some uphill stuff i did it i don't i i
think you can do it i think you should
do it
but um all of those things contribute to
the idea that it's probably going to
take
a little while before you actually start
making money
right and so that tells me i want your
emergency fund in place before you do
this
and that also tells me that the fastest
way to cause that to happen and the
fastest way to have then the money for
the licensing and the day care months
before you get money coming in probably
means you look at some other form of
extra income as a short-term way
to to get to your goal of being in real
estate faster
right like i mean if you could find
something and make a thousand fifteen
hundred bucks two thousand bucks a month
as a part-time gig doing something and
it just
you do the work it pays something uber
eats deliver pizzas
i don't care what you do or they'll hire
you to do something at that real estate
office for a couple grand
that would even be better uh and you're
just you know you just start
immediately doing that and i would
rather you do that than work real estate
today until you and
and use that money to get the emergency
fund finished faster and use that money
to get a little bit of a nest egg to
to go six months of day care and
1200 worth of upfront expenses and
you're gonna have more than that after
after all it's probably gonna be more
like two thousand by the time you're
done
um and so i i just want you to have all
that and
because nothing smells quite as bad as a
broke desperate salesperson
you're right and i i just have spoke to
with so many folks who want to get into
the real estate business that's why i
asked you what you want to do
because the mat the napkin math is so
great we just have to sell five houses
and i get this cut of this price and
honey we're gonna be rich and it's super
flexible so i don't even have to deal
with the little one anymore right
and everyone who i know dave and you've
done it i haven't gets into real estate
it is
all the time 24 7. it's closing deals at
9 00 pm
at 6 a.m a lot of work yeah a lot of
hours a lot of work a lot of
accessibility
so not trying to dissuade you i'm saying
you have a higher probability of being
in the real estate business five years
from today if you lay a really
cash strong foundation with an emergency
fund and your other cash up front before
you go in it's going to help you with
your success probability on this because
you do have probably a tough fight
i do think you should do it and i do
think you can do it
but i think it's going to be tough i
yeah
i just have worked with a good real
estate real estate folks and not good
ones man and it's such a it's such a
difference
it's incredible yeah it is and um and
they're everywhere
yeah i mean there's you know it is truly
the pareto principle 80
of the businesses done by twenty percent
of people in the business really
yeah and you take that that eighty
percent and it's another twenty eighty
twenty
again down to where you know one point
six percent are doing
you know the vast majority of
transactions it's crazy i mean so
you have one real estate agent is doing
400 transactions a year another one does
one transaction a year is it just
because it's a side gig or they just
don't hustle or
well no some people just reach another
level in their career they're another
level in the octane that they're
operating
off of and you know the protein just
drips off their eyelids you know and
it's just
uh and then uh you know and everything
comes together
you know and they some build teams to do
it with and everything else so
our elps we work with all the time you
know so we're looking at these high
octane people and
it's amazing you know uh
what can be done so i don't ever want to
be a dream killer
no but also don't want a dream turned
into a nightmare that's especially the
little one
yeah there you go hey jessica good luck
with it darling thank you for calling in
let us know how it works out i'd love to
hear from you when you're big time
successful real estate agent
john good show thank you sir dr john
deloney
and that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you